the god of light god of fire what i find
the most interesting about your book is
that's the god that i least want to have
powers maybe the seven
to protect all those people that are
praying to him for protection but they
never get protected
and yet varies is castrated
it's sacrificed into the fire and the
fire speaks back
and then we have the theme of course of
ice
of all of the evil that's coming when
winter is coming
is that i guess what i'm trying to get
at is that what the fire
and ice ice and fire is all about in the
book
well i'll let you figure out what ice
and fire is about in the book
but i will say one of the most important
things about
the books is the structure that i use of
viewpoint
characters you see everything through
the eyes of a particular viewpoint
character
and you hear things i'm i'm i don't
do omniscient narrative in other words
i'm not telling these from the viewpoint
of whatever god
so when you say the fire speaks back
well varys says the fire speaks back
when he's telling the story which is
then being retold
and it's 30 years later um you know you
might tell a story something happened to
you 20 years ago
and then if i look at a time machine
would it be exactly what you remember or
would time and memory have colored
things i want people to try to
kind of think about things we sometimes
get two viewpoint characters telling
very different stories about what
happened at the same event just as we do
in real life
um you know you can you can look into
newspapers and
even contemporary events and and
depending what newspaper or tv station
you put on you get a different version
of it
so there's a lot of subjectivity that's
involved here and that's a
deliberate authorial choice i love it
all right so i have some questions from
our fans
uh first question dennis ingram
he's the bassist for the sneaker kings
he wanted to know how long does it
usually take you to write a chapter
does it take more time for a certain
character's chapter for example
yes it does i mean typically and i've
said this many many times before but
tyrion has been
at least for the first three books
tyrion was the easiest chapter to write
his chapters virtually
wrote themselves when i hit books four
and five
tyrion's chapters became much harder to
write because he was in a very dark
place
and he was wrestling with a lot of
demons
and i really had to try to keep that in
mind at all time
bran was traditionally the hardest one
to write because he's a young character
he was the youngest at a regular cast
and um
the uh it's difficult to write from the
viewpoint of a kid because you you know
what's happening in the scene
but is the kid gonna know what's
happening in the scene is he is he
old enough to understand and you have to
try to put it in his language and
all that can be done but it takes time
it takes effort you can't just kind of
let it flow
so but yes as to how long it takes to
write a chapter well you know
two days um 10 years i've had
both cases extina
she's barrio honey on the cover of fresh
donuts wants to know
when will you give theon greyjoy a break
[Laughter]
well i don't know i don't think in terms
of giving the characters a break
but theon has been through some rough
times mind you but he's also done some
awful things
so maybe it's uh maybe it's karma i find
as a writer sometimes the most stressful
and exciting
opportunity is that you have a story
inside of you
and you have to figure out how you want
to communicate it
how do you come up with your overall
theme and narrative structure for a new
book like ice of
fire and game of thrones
you know i don't i don't think in terms
of overall themes or things like that
the theme emerges from the writing of
the book i think in terms of character
and incident and scenes and one thing
leading to
leading to another and looking at the
world
and and trying to tell the truth about
it uh whether it's the real world or
or a fictional world um you know i do
see these scenes in my mind
as a process of uh daydreaming i guess
it's not it's not night dreaming people
ask me if i
dream my stories i don't um but
but daydreaming sometimes doing nothing
i mean back
early in my life when i uh lived in
chicago
i had like a half hour commute on the l
to go to work
and just sitting there in the aisle and
watching the streets of chicago flash by
i would
a lot of stories would come to me then
just nothing to do i didn't read a paper
i just gazed out the window and at
daydreaming
scenes would start come and things and
pieces of dialogue and then you have to
get it down before it fades
onto the paper um
the scenes exist in your head in in a
kind of uh
pristine brilliance the hard work is
translating that to the paper and you
know you can see the battle
you can see the room now you have to
describe it so the reader can see it too
and
and our instruments are words which are
wonderful things i get drunk on words
sometimes but but they're also
stubborn crude instruments that don't
always fit what you want and you you
hammer at the sentence and it it's still
not getting across the way you see it in
your head so
how do you make it get in the head and
what order do you put it in that that's
the that's the struggle that's why
writing's so hard
absolutely